see in 1990 Joel Barker wrote a book
it's called paradigms he said to be able
to shape your future you have to be
willing and able to change her Paradigm
now I had no idea what a paradigm was
and you might ask yourself do you really
know what a paradigm is do you
understand how the mind works because
the Paradigm has something to do with
the mind I knew nothing about it but the
man that encouraged me to study this put
me on a track where I just kept going
from one great mentor to another a
paradigm is nothing but a multitude of
ideas that are fixed in the subconscious
mind and so here we are as hard as it is
to believe 20 30 50 60 years later
school gave us valuable knowledge
however school never taught us anything
about paradigms therefore we frequently
do not do what we already know how to do
now think Superior knowledge think about
it inferior results what does that do
that causes confusion and frustration
now think about this for a moment we've
gathered great knowledge but we know
nothing thing about the Paradigm so
watch here here's the drawing there's
the model there's all the knowledge we
got in school we've got it packed in
there but you know something it doesn't
equate to the results we're getting
you're going to find absolutely
brilliant people getting very bad
results you're going to find people that
are brilliant they know exactly what to
do but they don't do it why it's the
Paradigm that trolls the behavior hey
it's Evan Carmichael and I make these
videos because I need them because I
want to wake up every single day and get
pushed by somebody who's doing a lot
more than me and in watching their
videos it inspires me to be bolder to
have more courage and to go chase down
the life of my dreams and I hope it does
the same for you so today let's get some
incredible motivation from the one and
only Bob Proctor
enjoy
I want to talk to you about money about
earning more money and I don't care what
profession you happen to be in it really
makes little difference as far as the
subject is concerned
I have learned this is an educated
opinion it's something I've learned over
a long period of time that the earning
of more money
is only about five percent strategy 95
percent mindset
now why do I say that well
I was given this book
when I didn't have a nickel to my name
Think and Grow Rich my life has changed
dramatically since then
Think and Grow Rich by Napoleon Hill
then I got a hold of
Robert Russell's book you two can be
prosperous
here's an original copy from 1915
of Wallace Waddle's book the science of
getting rich
now the science of getting rich is the
book that inspired Rhonda Byrne to make
the the secret
which has been seen over a half a
billion people all over the world
and you know none of these books spend
much time talking about money
they almost spent all of their time
talking about you the reader
and your mindset
you see I know a lot of wealthy people I
have earned millions of dollars in my
lifetime and not by accident and it's
not that I was
that will
done well in school I went to high
school for two months and I met many
people who have earned millions of
dollars who have no formal education and
earning a lot of money is not luck
earning a lot of money is really getting
your mindset
you've got to know your worth
and then ask for what you deserve Hill
points out in here he said if you
believe hard work and honesty alone will
bring riches parisha thought is not true
riches when they come in huge quantities
are never the result of hard work now
listen carefully riches come if they
come at all in response to definite
demands
based upon the application of definite
principles and not by chance their life
yeah you've heard the old saying find a
need and fill it a definite demand and
then based upon definite principles well
these three books that I've just
recommended and I've got a whole library
of them behind me and they all Focus
on filling in demand
so you've got to start off by knowing
what you're worth Eric Hoffer put it
very well he said to learn you need a
certain degree of confidence not too
much not too little if you have too
little confidence you'll think you can't
learn
if you have too much you'll think you
don't have to learn I run into people
every day and fall into both of those
categories and I suppose we all fall
into both those categories more often
than we'd like to
we've got to have that certain degree of
confidence
no
what you're worth
and always be prepared to do more than
you're being paid for now that is one of
Hill's principles always be prepared to
do more than you're being paid for and
be prepared to walk away from anything
that is not serving you
now you've got to provide the service
but if a job is not serving you or if
something is not serving you walk away
from it and make up your mind you're
going to be a leader
you see money is a reward we see for
service rendered
be prepared to do more than you're being
paid for that is something that all
successful people will tell you fall in
love with what you're doing fill the
demand
but build the image in your mind that
you're worth it know what you are worth
you're God's highest form of creation
there is nothing on the planet that will
equal you
you might get a hold of these three
books and study them the signs are
getting rich by Wallace Waddles you too
can be prosperous by Robert Russell
those books are both out of print but
you can find them and of course
the one that's always on my desk
Think and Grow Rich what are some habits
that you do differently that maybe are
unexpected in the personal growth space
I study every day
every day I've studied every day now for
60 years
I started to study this book in 1961.
[Music]
and I read it every day same book Think
and Grow Rich I have just here behind me
I've Got The Laws of Success the
original ones that Napoleon Hill wrote
in 1928 and then he came up with this in
1937.
and the man that gave it to me he said
if you'll study this every day he said
you're going to have a wonderful life
and he pointed out Napoleon Hill spent
his whole life
studying the lives of 500 of the world's
most successful people he was mentored
by Andrew Carnegie who at the time was
the wealthiest man in the world
and he said since he spent his whole
life putting this together he said it
would be a prudent move in your part if
you spent the rest of your life trying
to understand and apply what he is
teaching and right you know that just
seemed to make some sense to me and
that's what I started doing I've never
stopped when you change your perception
you change your life
think of this
how many
different ways are there to look at how
you can live your life
and think of the number of people that
are saying I'm so sick of living the way
I'm living
change it
you can change it
there's a million ways you can have
we're God's highest form of creation
all the little creatures out there
completely at home in their environment
they blend in they operate by Instinct
we don't
we've been given higher faculties
we're totally disoriented in our
environment because we can create our
own environment my goodness when it
comes to earning money it's a piece of
cake now look it
man's mind stretched to a new idea never
goes back to his original Dimension
Oliver under Holmes said that a number
of people actually said that when you
stretch your mind to an eye with an idea
you'll never go back to its original
shape also to make sure you're actually
taking action after watching this video
I designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there we have the will
you know when President John Kennedy
asked Dr Warner Von Braun what it would
take to build a rocket that will carry a
man to the moon and Von Braun said the
will to do it he answered him in 10
seconds what would it take to build a
rocket that would carry a person to the
moon and bring back safely to Earth Von
Braun said the will to do it see the
willow is a mental faculty that gives
you the ability to hold one ID on the
screen of the mind to an excuse them all
outside distractions
there's a great golf tournament going on
right now and um well it was over
yesterday I guess wasn't it and and that
golf tournament one of the most
important things was the will the will
gives the the golf golfer the ability to
concentrate
and they can get their brain they mind
just like a laser concentrating that's
what the will does as you hold one idea
on the screen of the mind it to the
exclusion of all outside distractions
the will will do that
now it's a marvelous tool and most
people don't even know they've got it I
failed lots of times you don't learn
from your successes you'll learn from
your failures you get up and granted
again so you're not a failure until you
quit
failing is not hitting the mark but that
doesn't mean you're a failure
you failed but you didn't you don't
become a failure the only time you fail
here is if you quit you don't quit
you'd have to shoot me to stop me I mean
there's no quitting it doesn't it's not
part of the deal
there's no extra excellent strategy you
know where you're going that's where
you're going to get there feeling a
number of times I failed miserably if
you feel big enough it's exhilarating
I mean I've got some real Beauties
does that help
you just you just get up and get going
and don't you dare lay down
and I don't care if you're blow
everything you got listen I lost
everything I had one time and I uh it's
so clear to me I sat in the living room
I closed the front drapes I sat in the
dark in a great big chair
probably for a better part of a month
I was so despondent I lost
and then I don't know what moved me but
I got moved I went and I got
two long playing records
Earl Nightingales
narration not condensed narration is
narration of the book as a man thinketh
by James Allen
and I put those records on and I started
to play them
I got up I opened the curtains
and I went and bought a brand new
Cadillac car
I didn't have any money
but I knew the card made me feel good
when I got in it
and I went to work
that's very clear man that was a long
time ago
yeah just get up and keep going
if it's big enough you mean you're gonna
you'll grow you don't just grow from
your successes it's the trouble that you
grow if you see a large group of people
going one way and one or two going the
other way follow the one or two wow
the others have never known where
they're going to go 90 some percent of
the populations struggle all the way
through life
school doesn't teach us how to take
control of our life I don't care where
you go and I don't care how long you go
how far you go in school it does not
teach us how to control ourself
we've got to get involved with self
really understand who we are
um
so
everything every time you would caution
you you look around you see it was all
around you right everybody's telling you
you're crazy you can't do that
you know and when they quit the fire
department I quit the fire department go
and clean offices everybody thought I'd
really out of my mind in fact I was
really questioning myself at one point
um
because I was the second person since
1934 to quit the fire department no one
quit that job and they couldn't fire you
I mean it was like having a pension and
you only worked half the time
you know and when you were working at
night you'd sleep I mean it was like
being retired because I was in a slow
Hall if you're in a busy Place well
that's different downtown Toronto would
not be a good place
but any rate
um
I got into that
and I thought I can't stay here because
they were sitting around doing nothing
wanting to play cards or play darts and
I was thinking I know I gotta do
something I gotta do something so I
eventually quit
and I went and started cleaning offices
yeah what's the thing you don't want to
learn and understand that you feel like
you know what I haven't fully grasped
this concept or idea and I really want
to get to another level
well I'm always wanting to get to
another level hopefully I'm at a higher
level today than I was yesterday I I'm
in here around 5 30 every morning
studying wow that's how I start my day
here well
you see there is no end to the growth
you you always want to grow
so
you're created in God's image
now there's a problem with this
because we're raised on our physical
senses
we grow up
and what we've done is had God created
in our image in our mind
not that we're creating Gods I mean
we're taught that we created God in our
image so now we're trying to figure out
how can the man be omnipresent
how can that person be everywhere and
because we're locked in on a physical
level we get lost
when we understand
that you have infinite potential there
is no top
There's No Beginning No End
see when it comes to school of greatness
there's no Finish Line
when it comes to personal development
there is no Finish Line
so how can you tell how well you're
doing by the results you're getting
by their fruits by their fruits you'll
know them by the results they're getting
if they're not getting the results they
don't know so if you're going to get a
mentor get somebody that's getting the
results yeah
or you don't want them now you see here
on page six this says money is a servant
it's a servant
now there's a myth about money this is
another myth about money like you accept
money is that it only comes as a result
of luck or good fortune well of course
that is really silly that's not true at
all but that's the concept that a lot of
people operate with
okay now if you move over onto page
seven we're talking about money's got to
circulate it's not only a service you
got to keep it moving
I have some money here in my pocket
I keep it a little envelope
and this stuff here
is money
the truth is this represents money now
this used to be paper now I think it's
plastic you know use it as a fan but
this is It's a servant and you can put
this to work you've got to keep it
circulating
now we tell a story in here about
Mr Chapman now Mr Chapman was an
interesting guy
he lived on the street that I lived on
as a little boy
and my brother and I had a paper route
and we sold papers to the people on that
street we had 300 customers went right
from Kingston Road to the Lake Ontario
and almost every house we had as a
customer
Mr Chapman had a big house not too far
from our house up on a hill it was an
old house and one day Mr Chapman we used
to feel sorry for him he was he was
hunched back he was a little man he used
to push a little cart around and he
collected junk his wife was a a tall
thin lady and she always wore just
skimpy clothes like a cotton dress with
a maybe a little coat running shoes and
she would be off up the street she went
to clean houses or clean offices
we thought they were really poor
well one day we opened the paper we went
up the corner to get the papers and when
we got the delivery of the papers it was
headlines that Mr Chapman had died
it was a headline in the Toronto Star
they found a hundred thousand dollars a
hundred thousand dollars in a jar in the
house here he is collecting junk and he
had a hundred thousand dollars in a jar
in the house
now I just looked up that that up this
morning that's equal to one million
eighty seven thousand seven hundred and
ninety eight dollars in today's dollars
that's what a hundred thousand and
nineteen forty seven would have been uh
in today's dollars it'd be over a
million a million eighty seven eighty
eight thousand
he had all this money and he had it in a
jar
serving no one it wasn't circulating
we were shocked that he even had it
so
what we've got to understand
is that saving it like that is silly
like here the money that's in this
envelope in my pocket it's useless as
long as it's in an envelope in my pocket
it does no one any good
you may be saying why are you keeping it
there it won't stay it won't stay there
very long I'll have it circulating in a
very short period of time now if you
come down to the bottom of page nine
these are just Basics we're talking
about here about a Prosperity
Consciousness exercise
now that we have touched upon some of
the characteristics of money let us turn
briefly through a simple technique which
you can begin using immediately to start
attracting the amount of money that you
desire now think of that
you can literally attract to you the
amount of money you deserve you've got
to ask yourself where do I stand with
money we only have one problem in the
whole world and that's ignorance they're
living in ignorance they don't know that
what they're doing is going to keep them
where they are and they keep doing it
because they don't know how to change
they're overwhelmed with the debt
people are saying I need the money they
haven't got it
they want to take their family on a
vacation they don't have the money to go
so they may borrow it and go anyway now
they got more debt
they have to understand
that they don't have to live that way
I wrote a book called you're born rich
the truth is you are
most people are just a little short of
money but you are born rich rich and
potential anybody can go to our say go
to Bob proctor.com you can download the
book you were born rich
free it won't cost you a Cent and
chapter two is how much is enough
there's a it's described very well how
to get out of debt
you've got to create a debt repayment
program where it's all done
automatically and then you focus on
Prosperity you've got to have a
financial goal you've got to work toward
it and you've got to understand that you
can earn more than you're earning
and wealthy people don't have one source
of income they have more than one
I was earning money all last night while
I was sleeping yeah you can actually
earn more money when you're sleeping
than you can spend when you're awake
yeah you know it sounds like a cute line
but it's true
there's no end to what we can earn
if you are not getting information from
someone who is already wealthy then
you're probably getting information from
the wrong people most people ask their
brother-in-law the guy next door or the
girl they know
how do I earn more hell if they knew
they'd be earning it they don't know
and most people talk to people that
don't know Carlisle put it very well he
said he did not believe in the
collective wisdom of individual
ignorance and that's where most people
are getting it from people who don't
know any more than themselves
I think you have to go that's why these
seminars are so important today yeah
people have the opportunity to go and
learn most people won't pay to go
I tell people listen you invest in this
it'll probably be the important money to
do it it's probably the last time you'll
ever have to borrow money this is like
magic if you do the math repetitiously
you program you reprogram your Paradigm
you have no idea how many times I divide
multiply subtract I'm playing with the
numbers
I mentioned yesterday
I have gone from all the way from
Toronto to Kuala Lumpur I was going over
there once a month every month it's 25
hours near one way another 25 coming
back I would spend that entire trip
playing with the calculator
at the time I didn't understand what I
was doing I was really reprogramming my
subconscious mind it trained me to look
at a million totally different and
that's when one day I was on the plane
and I wrote down a million I thought
what the hell is the difference in
people that aren't a million I earned a
million and I'm trying to figure the
difference the difference is in their
own consciousness
it's in their own Consciousness and I'm
going to tell you something
I don't know any millionaires that have
got one income
millionaires have multiple sources of
income That's essential that's you know
I think um I'm always asked what do you
think of network marketing I think if it
didn't exist we should invent it I think
it's a great idea it accepts anyone
anyone can go in and you know something
it's multiple sources of income it's a
beautiful concept we have here in the
subconscious the Paradigm and part of
the Paradigm with respect
to money is it's a poverty thing
now this Paradigm impacts our thinking
there's a power flowing into our
Consciousness and the thoughts we think
are generally motivated by the
subconscious mind
now something that I've been pointing
out here recently on look at this
the subconscious mind is universal
intelligence
so when you have that Paradigm in the
subconscious mind that controls the
vibration that we're in
and the vibration we're in is going to
dictate what we attract because we're in
that vibration here on a conscious level
on the subconscious level and on a
physical so you're going to attract from
anywhere you go in the universe the same
type of thing that's that's what we're
attracting
so we're attracting people that are in
harmony with this and this Paradigm
causes our thinking to be along the same
level
now we've got to realize Even in our
ignorance when we don't know and we
haven't got anything our thinking is
hooked into Universal intelligence
and you will attract from wherever it is
in the universe whatever is required to
cause the problem when you hear people
say you know I just get one bill paid
and another one pops up bang they're
going to attract it
and sure as it gets dark they get it
now that's ingrained in our mind from
the time we're children
in fact
from the moment of conception in most of
us
and then we grow into it and that's what
we hear as we're growing up money
doesn't grow on trees and and over and
over you can't have everything you want
you know
and that is
um
that's got to be eliminated and we've
got to realize that is not fact
that you do not have to work harder
that you do less
and you earn more
and you've got to get the idea that you
can have money coming in from many
different places in the world dragging
right into you you're attracted
and you can magnetize yourself to money
in all different quantities I had an
affirmation that I used for years still
use it I'm so happy and grateful now
that money comes to me in increasing
quantities through multiple sources on a
continuous basis
I am so happy and grateful now that
money comes to me and
um in increasing quantities through
multiple sources on a continuous basis
and I just keep repeating that like a
mantra
and you're right out you know I'm so
happy and grateful now that
I have in my possession a million
dollars and that's where you started out
intellectually
then you get emotionally involved and if
you keep doing that ultimately you're
going to attract the money you could
spend um
oh God nine minutes
if you just write down write it write
this down right now I am so happy and
grateful
I am so happy and grateful now that I
have
multiple sources of income
I am so happy and grateful now that I
have multiple sources of income
you know
if you write that out every day for the
next 30 60 days
you're going to become very very aware
of having multiple sources of income
wealthy people all have multiple sources
they don't have one or two they have a
whole bunch of them
I don't know how many sources of income
I've got I'm not even interested in
figuring it out because somebody else
looks after that I don't look after it
but I do know that you can do that
that's what Keith did it down in New
Orleans God he just
his life changed so dramatically
and
I'll show you different things you can
do because anyone can you want to set up
multiple sources of income let the sand
in the glass here represent your life
the sand in the top of the glass
represents the future
the sand in the bottom of the glass
represents the past now here's the odd
thing about this you don't know how much
sand you have left in the top of the
glass
you may think you have a line you might
only have a little you may think you
only have a little and you might have a
lot we don't know
this is gone you can do nothing about it
the only thing you can do is what's
right here right now right in the center
if a person's listening to me right now
they can make a decision to change right
now just make the decisions you don't
have to know how
you don't have to know where the money's
going to come from you don't have to
know where the resources are come from
just make a decision
and then decide what you want how do you
find you find your life
ah your life's purpose
you don't find it you you well you do
find you discover it
our purpose
this is interesting your life's purpose
is your reason for living
um
I like the way my
good friend says it and
he put it the two most important days in
your life
of the day you're born
and the day you decide or discover why
you were born Les Brown says that all
the time
and I like him when he says that now
the day you're born and two most
important two most important days the
day you're born they discover why you're
born
your purpose is why you get out of bed
in the morning your purpose is why
you're living
I obviously have found my purpose I love
what I do I absolutely love it I'm
passionate about it I help people
understand who they are how to change
their life how to go from being broke to
becoming wealthy Beyond and happy to be
happy how to be in a bad vibration to be
in a Good Vibration
that that is my purpose I've studied it
I love it I live it
most people have never discovered why
they're here
how do you discover it you sit down and
totally relax get yourself a pad in a
little pen
and put it somewhere
beside a chair a favorite chair
um
discipline yourself maybe at the same
time every day early in the morning to
go and sit there and the only thing you
put in this pad
is what comes to your mind and ask
yourself it's a little game you play if
I could do what I loved every day that's
all I do is what I love every day
I come in here into this studio that I'm
in the Studio's in my backyard I can
broadcast all over the world from here
now my company built it for me
this is what I do and ask yourself if I
could do what I love all day what would
it be
that's where your purpose that's where
you're going to find your purpose
that's where you're going to find it
I watched I'll give you a good example I
watched a very pretty woman being
interviewed in television
and she
had been a dancer in a chorus A Chorus
Line and she said you know I was a
pretty good dancer but I wasn't the best
I knew I was always going to be in the
chorus I would never be the star because
that wasn't that good
and she said I liked it
but I didn't really love it
and she said I sat down one day and I
thought what do I really love do she
says I love baking pastry
quite a switch from dancing
she got out of the dancing business she
moved to France and went to work with
some of the best pastry chefs in the
world now when I started being
introduced or interviewed she was one of
the top pastry chefs in the world she
was doing what she loved that's what you
got to do you got to find out what do
you love
that's what you're going to be
passionate about and that's what you
should be doing
and it doesn't matter whether you're
earning any money at it or not you see
you don't earn money from working that's
a myth and it's not a very good one it's
a belief of most people and it's a silly
one you earn money by providing service
you can
you can earn more money when you're
sleeping than you could spend when
you're awake if you learn how to provide
the service I became obsessed with
learning how to eliminate doubt
and I've been researching this more and
just trying to learn from people like
yourself on how you have dealt with
self-doubt over the years and how you
think anyone who feels like they're
doubting themselves what can they do to
go from doubt into confidence what do
you think is the path okay that's a good
question it ties in with the previous
question you asked what do we do with
fear
fear comes from the doubt
the doubt becomes the cause of the fear
which is the cause of the anxiety Etc
the doubt is the cause fear is the
effect
what is the polar opposite to doubt
understanding
it's understanding that's the opposite
of doubt so what is it we want to
understand well if it's me that's
entertaining doubt
why am I entertaining though if I were
to find out who I really am
and I believe everything that's been
taught down through the centuries I
would have no doubt I would be realizing
that I could do anything
and the only thing that's causing the
doubt is a lack of understanding so I'm
going to keep studying I'll gain a
better understanding I don't doubt
myself I don't doubt what I can do
um does that mean that I can do
everything no when doubt appears I'll
eliminate it and I'll eliminate it fast
because I'm going to figure out how to
do whatever it is I'm doubting yeah
and you see if it's me that I'm doubting
it's because I don't understand me well
enough I did a broadcast the other day
it was all over the place we had
thousands into it on self-image
and we've got to get a better image of
herself we have to get a true image of
ourselves understand who we are how our
mind functions
realize this physical instrument we're
living in is nothing but an instrument
it's the instrument of the Mind
and the mind expresses itself within
through this thing we call our body
well let's understand that better this
thing you got enough power in your one
hand to light up that building you're in
for probably a month wow there's about
11 million kilowatt hours per pound
potential energy locked up in the
electrons in the atoms of the body well
that's the invisible power that's in me
I want to understand that better how
what that's the physical side what's the
higher side higher side is my
intellectual side and that is the
intellectual factors that I run through
earlier perceptional well reasoned
imagination memory and intuition there's
six of them and
as I understand those more as I
understand my intellectual factors I'm
using the things that I'm utilizing and
developing the things that separate me
from all the rest of the animal kingdom
of which I'm a part
then I can tap into the spiritual
essence of who I am
because we're Spiritual Beings and
that's where the greatness lies um
it lies in understanding the spiritual
essence of who we are you see our
spiritual DNA is perfect it requires no
improvement it requires no modification
our spiritual Essence is perfect and
that Perfection is within us so the
trick is figuring out how to express it
in a greater way targets
are good for the soul
yours and mine
you've got to have a real good goal
gotta have something you're really going
after that you really want
I knew that
you know what my goal was to find out
why I changed
that was very important because all of a
sudden
I realized I wasn't being very bright
I was doing very well but
acting pretty stupid
there was nothing responsible about how
I was acting
it took me nine and a half years to
figure out exactly why I changed how I
changed
because the change was
it was enormous it was like a
metamorphosis that had taken place
I was pretty much of a loner
when I was working with that I'd be
working with the people
but I spent a lot of time alone I spent
a lot of time thinking I really was into
reading and listening to recordings
when I figured out why I changed all I
wanted to do was share with other people
it is so simple
than most people miss it they don't
believe it
you've got to have a goal you've got to
have a Target you're shooting at targets
are good for the soul yours and mine
make no mistake about it I had been
raised to believe that if you're gonna
earn a lot of money you've got to be
really smart I knew I wasn't that smart
but I was earning a lot of money so I
knew that wasn't right
um
I was raised to believe if you don't go
to school you'll never get a good job I
didn't have a good job I owned the whole
company
I couldn't figure it out do you know it
took me nine and a half years
well nine and a half years later I met
this man
that I showed you his name Leland Val
vanderwaal he um he changed my life
completely
he introduced me to a concept I'm going
to introduce you to and when he did that
it was like everything I had been
studying I'd been studying a lot of
information
but I studied this book I'd give this
book to people and they didn't change
and what he did he brought everything
together for me in a role every short
period of time now here's a couple of
things he told me if you'll go back to
screen and he said Bob he he pointed it
he said you are a unique individual and
he said so am I so is everybody else and
he said you can literally create your
own economy you can do that
and he said the only thing standing
between you and what you want is
yourself
he's all about the Mind Bob he says it's
about your marvelous mind
then he started thanks God then he
started to talk to me about the mind and
he said you know it's a strange thing
Bob when we get talking about the Mind
nobody's ever seen the mind
they have never seen the mind now keep
in mind that I was a very uneducated
person
um when you talk about the mind I mean I
would think of psychiatrists
psychologists behavioral scientists now
he said you want to get rid of those
ideas he said the way I'm going to
explain it to you is the way it was
explained to me and he said we can
change we can show children how the mind
functions
and he said I'm going to show you
something here that's rather interesting
and he said Bob understanding the mind
and and working in harmony with the laws
governing the mind is essential if you
really want to win in life
and then he started to tell me what a
paradigm was and he said a paradigm is a
mental program that has almost exclusive
control over our habitual Behavior and
he started to talk about that he said
it's a program in your subconscious mind
that controls your behavior and the
Paradigm has almost exclusive control
over our habitual behavior and almost
all of our behavior is Habitual
so I said I want you why don't you think
about this and I want you to think about
it we get out of bed in the morning
we move into a routine
and if you're living with someone else
you don't mess around with their routine
because you just don't do that
we've all got a routine and we go into a
routine and we do that day after day and
most people do it for their whole life
Earl nandelia used to say most people
tip toast your life hoping they make it
safely to death it's rather an
interesting concept and the plan is the
program in your subconscious mind now he
said here's the crazy part about it Bob
the people that write this program the
ones that wrote the code for the program
[Music]
um
they really didn't know what they were
doing think of this for a moment I've
got a computer here it's in a phone I've
got another computer right in front of
me and then here I've got I've got a pad
and these are computers now there's
people write programs for these
computers
they write code and they really know
what they're doing and they're very very
good and the program for me to put the
slides up here that's a program it's a
PowerPoint program and these things work
like like a charm
well the people that are writing the
code for them are very well educated and
really understand what they're doing but
he said the people that are writing the
program for the code that runs your life
they didn't know what they were doing
now most people don't even know that
they have a program
think of this for a moment how do you
account for a person going to the very
best schools in the world getting
prestigious degrees
then spend the rest of their life losing
how do you account for that how do you
account for the fact that a person will
come up with degrees that will run right
off the end of a business card and maybe
not able to get a half decent job
very insecure how do you account for
that well I'm going to tell you how
there's a part of your mind that gathers
information there's a part of your mind
when you read the book you store the
information in that part of your mind
but that part of your mind is not the
part that controls the behavior of this
thing you're living in your body is an
instrument of your mind
it is an instrument of your mind and
it's your body then moves into action
and produces the results you're getting
the purpose of a goal is not to get is
not to reach the goal it's the awareness
that you develop as you go after it
you're learning Who You Are
is becoming aware of who you are
yeah
I was in a seminar years and years ago
and there was a speaker Bill Gove Bill
Gove
it was considered the Frank Sinatra
public speakers he was incredible
he had a handheld mic and he's looking
at the audience and he said
if I want to be free
I've got to be me
not to me I think you think I should be
not to me I think my kids think I should
be
not to me I think my wife thinks I
should be if I Want to Be Free I've got
to be me
he said I better know who me is you
might have to quit what you're doing
if you really don't like what you're
doing get out of it for God's sake
fall in love with something do what you
absolutely love doing if you really
don't like what you're doing you're not
in harmony with it you're not in harmony
find something else to do
look it
a lot of people are afraid to quit their
job because then what would they do
I was teaching I was thinking of this
last night after I taught this I was
teaching the vacuum love prosperity in a
seminar at the Hyatt Hotel in Downtown
Toronto
and we had in our kitchen a sofa a
little coffee table and a couple of
chairs and they were wicker they were
really I sort of like them
well anyway we were teaching the vacuum
La Prosperity I said if you don't like
something you should get rid of it
I went home one day and this was all
gone from the kitchen I said where'd he
go
they said we threw it out why we didn't
like it
you said to create a space for the good
you desire we created the space
that's that's the way it works you've
got to create a space for the good that
you desire well sometimes when you're in
a job you don't like and you say well
stay there till I find something they'll
quit quit get the hell out of it and sit
and think what do I really love doing
that's what you want to do results are
the name of the game
you've really got to pay attention to
the results you're getting
however
although you pay attention to results
you cannot let results control you
you've got to control results when you
let results control you you're toast
you're just gonna lose
results must never be in control of you
and that's really one of the big
problems that people make
and you're going to see how that works
most people don't even look at their
results because they don't like them
Mikey Stellar said that she's our chief
operating officer now I think that's so
true most people don't look at their
results because they don't like them and
it never enters their mind they're in
control they can change the results I
remember
my grandmother when I was just a little
boy because she pretty well raised me
she and my mother but my mother worked
all day and
grandma was the one that was home when
we were small
she would probably have been around 60
at that time
and you know every day of my life that
Grandma spent with us I think I heard
her say I'll soon be gone dear I'll soon
be gone
well you know it got to a point we
thought grandma was never going to go
of course she was a dear Soul she really
was
but
Grandma kept saying I'll soon be gone
she was 94 when she left 94. and from
the time she was 60 until she was 94 she
was saying I'll soon be gone
now around the same time I had a young
friend of mine Bob Yates
Bob and I went everywhere we did
everything together
we were as the saying goes as thick as
thieves and
Bob was two or three months older than I
was I guess he got his driver's license
two or three months ahead of me
and I remember Bob had this
sort of a panel truck
but it was on July the 9th 1951 Bob was
coming in the Kingston Road Highway and
there's one area that some of you would
be familiar with where you can either go
along onto Danforth or cut down onto
Kingston Road and Bob was cutting on
down to Kingston Road and it was
necessary to go under a concrete
overpass and as Bob come down there Wham
just like that he hit that concrete
overpass and like that Bob run out of
sand
16. now that was a terrible impact
in my life I'll never forget it
but if you had asked Bob a half hour
before that how much sand he had in the
top of his glass
he probably would have said half a
century for low
you didn't have a half an hour
now
I choose to believe that we all hope
that we're going to go to bed tonight
and we're going to get up tomorrow
morning we're going to go to bed
tomorrow night
but none of us know with absolute
certainty whether that's going to happen
or not
there's absolutely no way that any of us
can tell how much sand there is in the
top of our glass you've got to
discipline yourself
this is the ability to give yourself a
command and then follow it quit fooling
around with your life for God's sake
this is our life and it's very short
look at this for a moment
see this here
the sand and the glass represents your
life
you want to see something really funny
the sand
in the glass represents your life the
glass used to be sand
that's right the glass used to be sent
we changed the molecular structure of
the sand and we turned it into glass
we've got the ability to do that but you
know something the glass the sand the
sink everything and me we're all in the
same frequency
we're all energy now look at this is the
past this is the future
you don't know how many stains you have
left in the future all you can look at
is what you've got in the past and
what's right here right now right in the
center that's all you've got to work
with so make a decision and make up your
mind you're really going to make things
happen the mind and the loud vibration
are two things when you start to
understand them everything starts to
improve when you really understand them
you take control of your life
you've been given the ability to do that
all you have to do is learn how and I'm
going to show you how here in the next
30 minutes let that drawing that Circle
represent your mind there's two parts to
it if you notice that there's a
horizontal line right through the center
let's put a body on it we'll say that's
the body and the top half is the mind
and we'll bring it down here to work
with it see there you've got your
conscious mind then you have your
subconscious mind and then the
instrument of the mind because that's
what the body is and the body moves into
action and produces results see the body
acts according to the vibration it's in
not only are we getting the results we
got but we also have a picture in our
mind a dream we've got this beautiful
star that we want to shoot at
and you see that dream is up there
but it's up there
and it's on a different level it's an
invisible world
it's where only one person can see it
you only one person can see it me Earl
Nightingale put it very well I spent
five years working with Earl it was a
marvelous experience he said this great
dream this surging Dynamic thing
invisible to all the world except to the
person who holds it is responsible for
every great advance of humankind
now you see this is the world we relate
to down here this is the visible world
the physical world and we live to our
senses we go by what we see here smell
taste touch we get a report card and we
let the report card tell us what kind of
students we are we graduate from school
and the report card becomes the balance
sheet or the bank account
let's understand that anything we see
outside was originated inside that's
right now it's the space here that we
want to close we want to understand how
to close that space how do we go from
where we are to where we want to be
that's rather an interesting question
you see
this is where the attraction starts it
starts here in the non-physical world
now this is a mind game you must
understand the mind if you're really
going to make it happen and when you
study this and start to understand it
then you attract according to the
vibration you're in and you'll start to
understand that you control the
vibration your brain is electronic
switching station as you activate brain
cells you alter the vibration you're in
as you alter the vibration you alter
what you attract into your life today
can be the turning point in your life by
making a simple decision
but if you don't make decisions you're
going to stay right where you are we
have to make decisions
if we're going to change
um we have to change the direction that
we're going and when we change the
direction we're going and then we want
to make sure we're going in the right
direction
because if we're not
um
we're going to either go backwards or
we're going to stay where we are
now I um I had something pretty
interesting happen when I committed to
study this material every day and
and follow proven Direction
the change that took place was enormous
and you know what can be for you now
there's one thing that you absolutely
require if you're going to make a big
change and that's discipline
see without discipline nothing happens
and I found that discipline is the
ability to give ourselves a command and
then follow it
I'm going to suggest as we go through
this and I um I suggest you make some
decisions don't look at somebody else
and say what are you going to do do what
they're going to do has absolutely
nothing to do with where you're going
it's what are you going to do that's
what really makes the difference what
are some some things you think people
that in their teens or even in their 40s
and 50s who don't have confidence yet
one of the things we can be doing
differently to gain confidence to build
self-esteem because I think this is one
of the key factors of successes
believing in yourself it doesn't matter
if the world believes in you if you
don't believe in you yeah what can we
start to do to change that well I think
a person has to start to study
themselves
most people know very little about
themselves they think they're their body
you're not a body you have a body
and you have a marvelous mind
and
when I first started to study this I
thought you know
study in the mind that's for
psychiatrists psychologists behavioral
scientists
and the man that told me he said no it's
not he says that's for anybody that's
for little kids
and so I think as we start to understand
something about our mind
and something about our higher faculties
see we're all programmed to live through
our senses we go by what we see here
smell taste touch
well I've got a little dog at home that
you see here smell taste touch
all the animals in the world they're
they're completely at home in their
environment they blend in
they operate by instinct which is
perfect
um we at Instinct removed and we had
higher faculties put in our place in
their place and if we would study these
and gain an understanding your
self-image would automatically start to
improve
you have perception the will
reason
imagination memory and intuition
those six faculties
will give you the ability to create your
own environment see we're totally
disoriented in our environment where all
the other little creatures are
completely at home in theirs and we're
we're disoriented in Earth because we
can create our own but we don't know
that
school doesn't teach us that
school is more interested in
the development of your intellect than
in the development of awareness
um
like
a person doesn't earn a hundred thousand
dollars a year because they want a
hundred a year you're in 100 a year
because they're not aware of how to earn
100 a month
awareness is really the key and when we
become aware of who we are and what
we've got working for us
you know marvelous things start to
happen to us
and that's really what happened to me
I never went back to school
um
I um
I built a very successful company it
operates all over the world
um
I didn't do myself
I have tremendous team of people I've
got a just an absolute Genius of a
business partner a a woman who's an
attorney I mentioned to you before you
should have her on sometime you shoot
you'd be fascinated with her she's that
interesting but
it was a group of people we've attracted
a phenomenal group of people in our
company
and we're operating now in 91 countries
wow teaching this information
you know
it's
I don't know another company that
teaches what we teach
like I think
Tony Robbins has probably done more for
our industry than any individual the
secret has probably done more for it as
much as Tony has
um the movie
um
but there's I don't know anybody else
teaching what we're teaching
and what we're really doing is teaching
people how their mind functions and um
how to expand their understanding of how
it operates what would you want someone
to do Straight off today stop listening
to this episode as they go back into
their own life after listening to you
today what do you want them to do what
do you who do who do you want them to be
where would you like them to start I'd
like to ask them to ask themselves what
do I really want in this life
what do I really want
and take a pen
and write it down
what do I really want in this life
they might start out what do I love
doing
I think that's where you start your
purpose in life is what you love
I'm living my purpose so your purpose is
why you're alive why you get out of bed
in the morning
and some people never figure that out
they never even give it any thought
when it's probably the most important
question a person can ask themselves
if you started what do I really love
doing that's a good place to start do
you know I had a a doctor here oh
probably a couple of years ago now in
Phoenix
he was in a seminar and he said um
he was telling me he was thinking of
quitting the medical profession I said
why are you going to quit
well he said you got to put in a lot
more time to earn less money today and I
said well I've heard that
he said the medical profession's all
messed up and I said well I've heard
that too
I said why did you become a doctor
well he said I love it
why would you want to quit
well he said because you can't earn I
said wait a minute I said if you're
doing what you love if you never earned
a dime
you're spending your days doing what you
love to do that's a trick of life
I said your problem is you think you
were in money by going to work you work
to earn money you don't work turn money
people earn the most money don't work at
all
you earn money by providing service but
you gain satisfaction from doing what
you love
and there's two forms of income one
satisfaction the other's money
it's a material thing
but I said if you're not getting
satisfaction of what you do you should
quit it
because it said that's where it comes in
that's why we should figure out what we
love to do and then dedicate our life to
it
I got into this business I had been
studying it for quite a while
and I had the opportunity I already
mentioned a visiting girl night girl
and I was leaving his office right at
the end and I said Earl what is the big
deal in life
well he said there isn't any big deal
Bob he said
it's simply a matter of sitting and
figuring what you love to do and then
dedicate your life to it so the problem
with most people is they never figure
out what they love to do well I'm
telling I can feel the hair going up in
the back of my neck I knew exactly what
I love to do I'm doing what he was doing
I was and I wanted to do it with him
I had a very busy company at the time
we're operating Canada the US and
England
but I knew that I was finished doing
that I was going to come back I was
going to work with him two years later I
was his Vice President of Sales I wanted
to in the what he was doing be in the
business he was in
and that's where I made the decision and
I love it I love what I do
now
that's what people should be doing what
do I love to do then dedicate your life
to it now you earn money by providing
service you earn money while you're
sleeping just figure out how to serve
people
you don't have to be there you don't
have to physically be there and do it
you can serve people while you're
sleeping and get paid
and that's how you're in money so you
got to learn how to earn money but that
has got nothing to do with
a life of Living what you love that's
the first place so if I was telling
anybody sit down figure out what you
love to do and then make up your mind
you're going to dedicate your life to it
what stops most people what they love to
do they think you can't earn any money
at it that doesn't matter
[Music]
forget about the money
that's another subject figure out how to
earn it go talk to people and not earn
money I know how to earn money I could
teach people how to earn money but that
is not the thing is to provide service
so the most important thing what do I
love to do sit down what would I really
love to do how would I love to spend my
life
that's what we should do
and unfortunately most people never get
involved in that exercise you're a
spiritual being that's who you are you
are pure unadulterated spirit
you're an extension an expression of God
whatever your concept of God is we see
God as everything
the
all-knowing power that is all-powerful
all-knowing omnipresent and you're a
spiritual you're in you're you're a
spiritual expression
and as such all knowledge is with you
you have all knowledge you have all
power
you just
don't believe it
into the degree that we believe it we
have it
and the trick of life I see is
developing our belief system
our belief system is based upon our
evaluation of something and frequently
if we reevaluate a situation our belief
about that situation will change
that took me nine and a half years to
figure that out
I was sitting having something deep with
Val vanderwaal he was a marvelous mentor
of mine and I had been reading the Bible
the New Testament the Old Testament The
Book of Mormon the bhagavad-gita the
Quran the Torah I mean I was seriously
studying on all this because there's
only two sources of reference you can go
to to find out about yourself one
science and the others theology
and they all teach you essentially the
same thing they come at it from
different angles and in everyone
everywhere they tell you got to believe
belief is an absolute prerequisite you
don't believe it ain't going to happen
well
I'm thinking how do you believe I mean I
know somebody how do you believe them
they don't know how do you believe
I was having something to eat with him
one day in the restaurant I can still
see the two of us sitting there and in
idle conversation that come out he said
our belief system is based upon our
evaluation of something and frequently
if we reevaluate a situation our belief
about that situation will change
well it was just like rockets going off
in my head I got him to repeat what he
said and I realized that's why my life
had changed I was studying this non-stop
non-stop non-stop everything I kick in
my hands get my hands on so I was
continually reevaluating who I was
and because I continually reevaluate my
belief kept changing it kept changing it
kept changing and of course my results
kept changing my results were a
reflection of my own belief
I just know that if I get an idea I can
execute that idea I don't know how long
it's going to take me I don't know where
I'm going to get the resources brought
in new I do know it's going to happen
that's what William James said believe
and your belief will create the fact I
think there's a lot of people writing
books that really don't understand what
they're saying and their understanding
is very shallow
um I think the secret to
understanding how to really get to know
ourself we have to go to people that
have demonstrated by results they really
know what they're talking about like I
always say that eighty percent of the
people in our teaching have never done
what they're teaching
and if you haven't done it I don't think
you really understand it so it's not
what you know it's what do you do
and for years companies were paying
people based on what they
thought they knew it was gone by a
degree and the durray didn't indicate
they knew anything at all and that they
had gathered information but
I think we have to go by what they do I
was very fortunate when I started to
study
the first man that helped me the first
person that helped me was a man
and he's the one that introduced me to
this book
just I've got to help with an elastic
now let's Think and Grow Rich by
Napoleon Hill and
he knew what he was talking about
and he said if you do exactly what I
tell you you can have anything you want
well I didn't believe that
but I believed he believed it and he did
and he did know what he was talking
about so I was I feel I was particularly
fortunate
in that I met someone like that
and
I think probably it was an unconscious
thing in the beginning
if I followed anyone from then on
I looked what they were doing before I
started to listen to them
I look at their results before I start
to pay attention to them
and that has been sort of a
a guiding principle in my life
I believe if you want to learn something
you have to go to someone that knows
more than you do
and that's really what I've done
and I've had five or six people that
I've followed over the past 60 years
it's been 60 years since I started to
study this
and
I followed that principle and I think
it's a it was a good sound principle to
follow if you're not calm
you're tied up in a knot
you caught you solved nothing
energy flows to and through us
when we're uptight it's like putting a
kink in a garden hose and wonder why the
water doesn't flow freely yeah if you
want the energy to flow freely through
you and get good results you've got to
become
so the trick is don't let anything
outside really upset you
now there's another side to this
if you let something outside get you
excited you're gonna let something
outside get you depressed because you're
reacting to what's going on outside so
something really good happens you get
excited something bad happens you're
going to get depressed that's because
you're letting the outside control you
I don't think you should get excited
about anything I think you should get
enthused about it see
excitement has a polar opposite
and it's depressed
enthusiasm doesn't have a polar opposite
enthusiasm is in God it comes from the
Latin and Theos in God
and it just is
just is now they're going to read just
this everything just is in truth you
know so it's a bit of a philosophy you
got to get into it and then you train
yourself to think and live that way I
had a man sit down with me and he did
essentially what I'm going to do with
you right now he said Bob I want you to
take a look at the results you're
getting in your life really take a look
at the results
and then he got me to think he said how
do results happen Bob how do they
actually happen
and
I didn't know he says to to results just
happen
well of course results don't just happen
and this is where this word man
approached me back in 1961. he uh he
said I want to magnify the results that
you're getting in your life really take
a close look at it because he said
people are just falling short in a
couple of areas
and he pointed out that we're only
limited by weakness of attention and
property Poverty of imagination in other
words we got to stay focused and we've
got to use our imagination to build the
kind of world we really want
now I think that's what you want to do
that's what I want to do
I don't think you were looking for
something to do when you sat down to
watch this
you see
I believe that you do want to improve
the quality of your life
and a man named Ray Stanford sat down
with me a long time ago in 1960
one and he put an r on a sheet of paper
and then he put
an H he said Bob that's happiness
he said that represents health and that
represents wealth
now he said I want you to look at those
three areas of your life
are you getting what you want to get are
you doing what you want to do he's I
need to tell you something about results
results always tell the truth
by their fruits you'll know them results
always tell the truth you can kid
yourself all over the place if you want
but look at the results I have people
they'll tell me how much they know about
this or about that take a look at the
results
the results tell the truth if you're
playing golf the scorecard the scorecard
tells the truth
you see
now think
your bank account tells the truth your
sales sell tell the truth your position
in life the health of your body what do
you think are the three most difficult
habits to develop uh that actual
actually will support us for the most
growth long term if we can take these
habits on one thing I think the most
difficult is repetition of studying the
same thing
um I have a
a book here on my desk
it's in a book holder
and
when I went to visit Earl nightgale away
back 1968.
six no is other than that it was around
66. and I saw he had this
book stand on his desk and I asked him
what it was he said it was a book holder
and I said why do you have it he says
because I want to read those two pages
every day for the next month maybe two
months
I said really
the same thing and he said yeah
he said then they'll become a part of me
hmm and he said that's really the
success The Secret of success is
repetition of an idea you see that in
sports you play ball I mean
it's definitely part of your game and if
a person will really understand that
it's through repetition that you program
your subject of mind and it's your
subjective mind that controls your
behavior
doesn't make sense to some people but
if they would study it and start to
understand they would start to do it I
want you to imagine that there's a power
flowing into your consciousness
this power flows to and through us and
it never stops now when the power flows
into our Consciousness we could call it
thought power if you choose you can
think anything you want you can think
anything you want
no one can cause you to think something
you don't want to think Victor Franco
spent the War years in a concentration
camp he was a Viennese psychiatrist he
wrote a marvelous book Man's Search for
meaning and it was on logotherapy and he
said regardless of the intellectual or
physical abuse he was subjected to no
one could cause him to think something
he didn't want to think now whatever
thought you think you turn over to your
subconscious mind but the subconscious
mind is programmed and again I'm sorry
we don't have the time to get into
paradigms the way we'd like to but it is
programmed what we want to do is learn
how to control the flow of this energy
we want to learn how to control the flow
of thought energy and let it flow freely
to and through US improving everything
with which it connects
you see we're really in charge of our
results the results that we get in our
life can be altered
without any difficulty
now I keep apologizing not being able to
go into this in the depth I want to but
as I give you this concept I want you to
pay very close attention because on a
conscious level you have a choice you
see those two symbols one's negative
one's positive now if we just back this
up a bit there is the power flowing in
you can think anything you want you can
choose to think of what you don't want
or you can choose to think of what you
do want you can look at what's wrong
with lifer you can look at what's right
with it you do have a choice
that power
you can build it into anything you
choose unfortunately most people stay in
an ignorant State they never really
understand themselves
now ignorance is simply not knowing the
opposite of ignorance of course is
knowledge
knowledge is readily available to us
libraries are full of knowledge seminars
today just dispense all kinds of
knowledge some of it's very valuable
some of them may not be but there's a
lot of knowledge around about you about
what makes you tick and why you live the
way you live now we have a choice and we
can choose whatever we want you can
choose to think of what's wrong or you
can choose to think of what's right
why would a person choose to worry and
don't
well if we back it up the problem is
ignorance that is really the problem
they don't understand the situation
see doubt and worry are both psychic
diseases
it's plugged into a negative side of
life this power flows in you can build
anything out of it you want and what do
we do we worry why do we worry well
there's not enough money to meet our
needs or the things might not turn out
the way we choose we've got the ability
to choose anything we want now when we
build a negative idea and that's what
we're doing we're taking the uh there's
power and building a negative idea we
take then impress that negative idea
upon our subconscious mind
the subconscious is the emotional mind
so we're getting emotionally involved
with a negative idea that sets up a
vibration called fear
fear is a negative emotion the cause of
it the primary causes ignorance but the
the root cause then is worry or doubt
now when that fear is expressed and it
must be expressed through the body see
it comes in and has no form we build an
idea a negative idea and we impress it
that sets up fear and when it expresses
it it expresses itself in anxiety
people do not enjoy anxiety it causes
all kinds of problems anxiety is not
expressed anxiety is suppressed
it's suppressed
what happens when we suppress anxiety
when we bottle that energy up inside it
turns into depression that's what
happens how do we keep positive and
motivated in the journey
of cleansing our paradigms towards our
soul how do you keep a sustained level
of enthusiasm in this journey that
actually requires quite a lot of
profound internal work
I think you were said the right word
there in enthusiasm
I think people are looking for
excitement
yeah yeah very well and there's quite a
big difference
absolutely I've always pointed out when
you see a person that gets excited when
something good happens you're going to
see somebody gets depressed when
something bad happens
and
there's a great lesson in that
but rather than getting excited we
should get enthused we want to look for
enthusiasm come from it comes from in
Theos which is in spirit
and everything just is
and if we can look at it it just is it's
neither good nor bad
it just is we're not going to get
excited we'll get enthused
and if we look at the negative it just
is
not going to depress us because it just
is so I think the trick there is to
understand the difference between
enthusiasm and excitement
and how do you maintain the enthusiasm I
think the only way to maintain it is to
continually study Who You Are
never stop studying and now
I don't think you just sit and study do
nothing else you have to study you have
to study understand and you have to
apply it
so it all comes out in results
now I have found a great way to measure
results is in money
you can measure it to the penny
people say happiness or health you can't
measure a person's happiness and you
cannot measure their health
you can go and you can have a checkup
and they'll say guys in perfect healthy
walks over the doctor's office a bang he
drops dead he wasn't in perfect health
at all and it appeared he was
and
but in earning money you provide service
but you got to control the money you
don't let the money control you
and then
if you fall in love with the idea of
providing service and it's in a profit
making way you can earn a lot of money
well then you can put that money to work
to do great things with
and that's sort of the path I'm on
and like my partner and I we build
schools over in Africa
and we do them through a Cynthia Kersey
out there in Los Angeles is she's the
Unstoppable Foundation
and
we take a lot of joy in that
we have people from the company go over
and see the work that we're doing you
know that they're contributing to
so I think you um
you've got to keep checking your results
and you have to keep raising your own
level of awareness and the only way to
do that is to continue these study
and but control your life don't let life
control you
so you're living from the inside out
which sounds very esoteric or
philosophical
but it's the only way I can explain it
because that's really what you're doing
most people use their imagination they
use it the wrong way they imagine what
won't work they imagine something bad
happening
um what should we imagine more often
every day we should imagine you should
see yourself where you want to be you
got to live there
there's a great book you may be familiar
with Stella Adler's book The Art of
acting oh gosh you've got to get it
Stella Adler was a great acting teacher
she was a method acting teacher she did
she studied and understands Lasky the
the Russian acting teacher that
originated method acting okay Marlon
Brando wrote the forward in her book he
was the first
method actor to reach super stardom okay
and
he wrote forward in your book now still
Adler never actually wrote a book a man
named uh Kissel
took all of her teaching all of her
lessons for teaching and she put them
into it or he put them into a book so
when you read her book you're going to
her acting classes
and
like Shakespeare said we're all actors
you know the world's the stage when
that's true
well when you reach a goal you're going
to act like you're already there
it's already happened intellectually the
second you think about it it's already
happened emotionally when you're
emotionally involved with it so it's
only a period of time until it manifest
in physical form right
because it's not in physical form we act
like we haven't got it yet yeah well so
that's why most people stay stuck
because they're acting like they haven't
got it yet
or if I can't act like that Lewis would
see that I haven't got that result he'll
he'll think I'm phony I gotta quit
worrying about what Lewis thinks and
start concentrating on what Bob thinks
and so you see yourself your imagination
you're going to be that person
said that great philosopher he said
before you can do something Universe
must be something so you've got to be it
intellectually you've got to be it
emotionally and say someone says as a
person thinks then they're hurt your
emotional mind
well it's only a period of time then
until it manifest physically that's one
of the first laws the universe is the
Perpetual transmutation of energy energy
is moving into form always to form
moving into forms through form back into
form again
so we cause it all to happen the way we
think
and the way we stay locked into ideas
you know
how should people be developing their
imagination on a daily basis
in a positive way my wife think they
should take time to image what they want
I have a business partner
um Sandy Gallagher who's a brilliant
woman
and she rides horses gated horses and
she's in Kentucky right now and
big
term or shows there
she images herself as a world champion
every day
she takes the time and she sees herself
as a world champion she sees herself
getting Neurosis getting the whole thing
and that's where you should do it I
think you build the image of what you
want
I mean you obviously image this studio
before you ever built it right I mean
everything you see here was part of the
image in your mind but everything you
create you create twice once in here
once out here you know so you never get
an original painting you always get a
duplicate the picture's in here wow
so we have to see ourselves with what we
want here
now we've got enormous
uh deterrent in our Paradigm we're
conditioned
genetically and environmentally
and that conditioning is controlling
most people's lives that's why brilliant
people are broke brilliant people are
unhappy brilliant people never really
accomplish very much they're absolutely
brilliant
but their Paradigm is controlling them
it's all about intellect
they're smart people
but like
you got to consider where we come from
a little particle of energy from a
little particle of energy from Dad come
swimming on
that's a nucleus of us
then that goes on for 280 days
attracting more energy until you
make your debut on the planet and then
your program environmentally by your
environment
so everything that's going on is going
right into your subconscious mind so you
come out you're programmed genetically
we go we don't know how far it grows
back four or five generations possibly
like when I was a young man I had red
hair my mother didn't have red hair my
dad didn't have red hair I got a brother
and sister and they don't have red hair
because you'll think well but my
mother's father you know his brothers
had red hair so sometimes it jumps a
generation
that's why we look like our relatives
it's genetic conditioning and then
there's environmental conditioning we
know almost all welfare recipients our
fourth fifth generation welfare
recipients
so this is passed down in generation to
generation
now unfortunately we're all or
fortunately we're all exactly the same
we got exactly the same potential our
spiritual DNA is perfect you're building
an idea
and you're planting it in Universal
intelligence now when you do that
when you do that what you want to
understand
is that you planted that idea
here
that idea then
is planting Universal intelligence so
it's drawing from anywhere
anything that's in harmony with it
you see this
is a vibration it's a frequency and we
have put ourselves on a specific
frequency when you hold that idea when
you're emotionally involved that must be
expressed with and through you whatever
you need is in the universe and this
idea is going to attract it to you
because the idea controls the vibration
that you're in the vibration you're in
controls what you how you act but it
also controls what you attract
this is very important you get this your
subconscious mind is um it's like
Universal intelligence
and
that idea then
um
is on a specific frequency
well then
thank you
we're Spiritual Beings
this is the spiritual side of you now
everything spirit
the intellect and the physical
but when you plant the idea here
it's planted on a specific frequency
it's almost like when I phone somebody
what I'm doing is I'm tuning in on a
particular frequency and they're on that
frequency and when I press a number
their phone rings doesn't matter where
they are they could be anywhere in the
world you see when it comes to Universal
intelligence you eliminate all time and
space there's no such thing as time and
space everything's in the now everything
is in the now and it's important that we
understand that
and when we understand it good things
start to happen to us
okay
now that idea
will attract to it anything that's in
harmony with it so whatever you need
will come to you but it won't come to
you before you need it
and we're very impatient and we want to
do this part before we get this part
done
you got to do things in the order
you see this part is operating by law
it's operating by law
because it's Universal intelligence and
the law is Perpetual transmutation of
energy that idea instantly begins to
move into form
and it attracts whatever is required but
it also causes you to act the way you
have to act so it's the action and
attraction that ultimately produces the
result
how long does it take for that to
manifest we don't know
that's governed by a law called law of
gender that law decrees that all things
have a gestation or an incubation period
I want you
to stop and think of something you
really want
that maybe the thoughts on your mind
frequently that you really can't get
now let's clearly understand this is
what I've got on the screen here is what
we do far too often
far too often we let the bank balance
control our head now I never let that
happen
do you know why I never look at the
balance I've never balanced a checkbook
in my life I've never and I don't intend
to ever do it I don't want to do it I
think it's terrible work I don't want to
do it now does somebody have to do it
absolutely and I've got people working
with me they're Sandy Gallagher is a
genius out there she just absolute
Geniuses and so I liked her being able
to do it she's a genius at I don't want
to do it I don't want to let results
control my thinking
I prefer to do this
now look here
I'm going to take this and this is what
I'd suggest you do and rub this out
prep present results out
and then start thinking here
we know that there's a power that's
flowing into our consciousness
we know that
and this power as it flows in it just is
it's neither positive
or negative
it just is
and we can make out of it anything we
want
I've got the idea here
I'm not telling you what it is I'm going
to show you what it is
Mikey and I are going to discuss it some
more
we get this idea here now she's going to
take this to the marketing team
and they're going to start talking about
it now let's understand this
you can do what I'm suggesting here and
when you do this you then become this
this is you here you become like you're
magnetized
and and and and you just it's like
whatever idea you hold
you impress upon your subject of mind
this is the part that you've got to try
and get straight
this part here
okay
your subconscious mind
is part of everything
's hooked together remember I say the
love is a vibration there's no line of
demarcation they're all joined together
each one is hooked up to the one above
and the one below that's everything in
the universe is connected like that
now
and you can change it you have the
creative ability to change it
you see this here here's a an hourglass
the sand in the glass
is running here it never stops
the glass that's holding the sand used
to be sand
now think what I'm saying
the glass that's holding the sand used
to be sand
but we have learned how to alter the
molecular structure change the vibratory
rate of the energy that we call Sand and
we can turn it into glass then we can
mold it whatever way we want we can make
an hourglass out of it
it's energy the energy that we call that
is glass we call this sand because of
the vibration it's in we call this wood
because of the vibration it's in okay we
call this skin we call this hair we call
this cloth
it's all energy and it vibrates
everything is hooked together because
every frequency is connected to one
above and the one below
when you get emotionally involved
with an idea and you really get it to
sink into your Consciousness you move
your body into a vibration but the mind
body is in the vibration and you are in
sync intellectually emotionally and
physically the Consciousness and the
subconscious in the body on the same
vibration
you have a strong a strong attractive
Force setup
and that is strong attractive Force
that's going to start attracting to you
from every side of the universe
whatever is necessary
to manifest that idea in physical form
or in results
that is the result you want to see not
the not the one that exists now when you
look at the present result that's
thinking in reverse and that's what this
night chapter 9 is about most people
think in Reverse do not think in Reverse
quit looking backwards
it's a waste of time and a waste of
energy and it's very destructive for
your own future if you could go back and
with all the wisdom that you've gained
over the years if you could go back and
tell 10 year old Bob some advice give
them some advice based on everything
that you've learned what advice would
you give them
set a goal
always have a goal I have in my pocket
the gold card
I've been carrying a gold card in my
pocket for years
since 1961.
when you decide on a goal
you paint the picture in words when you
do that you impregnate the picture into
a group of cells in your brain
every time I touch that gold card it
triggers the picture in my mind
and as long as that picture is there I
keep moving in direction of it
and that is really the secret I think
to living a good life you've got to have
a reason for it when you wake up in the
morning you have to have a good reason
for waking up and going to going to work
I think we should be thinking about the
uh the greatness like it's the school of
greatness I think we ought to be
thinking about the greatness that we've
got lost got locked up within us and
bring it to the surface everyone has
deep reservoirs of talent and ability
Within
and they can bring it to the surface to
accomplish anything they want
now to sit in fear
and wonder what's going to happen
hmm that is a dumb waste of your talent
and your time yeah
and unfortunately
that's what most of the media is uh
promoting right now
to believe in fear is to believe in
something you can't see to believe in
faith is to believe in something you
can't see well if you have a choice I
think I choose Faith over faith
absolutely
I think I believe where I can really see
something happen I believe we're going
to have a phenomenal year in our company
wow
in fact
I'm a business partner Sandy Gallagher
and uh very bright lady
was a Securities attorney prior to
joining us
she run a program this morning for um
our entire company we have about 70
people and the company she was teaching
masterminding to them all and saying how
this is important that every one of us
get involved in this that we learn the
basics of masterminding that Napoleon
Hill uh brought to the world
let's say
way back in the 30s
now I think that's what we should be
teaching people
uh Sandy was on the right track there so
I think we ought to be thinking about
what we're going to build how big are we
going to do it where are we going to do
it when are we going to start
our goals have not changed
they're very big they're very ambitious
and we're not letting this virus slow us
down one bit yeah as a matter of fact
we're trying to figure out how can we
use this to speed it up so if you care
and you can't you can't get rid of it
use at your advantage yeah there is a
way we can use it to our advantage
people are more dependent upon the phone
uh I've got a computer here they're
dependent on their phone their computer
more than they've ever been
we can reach them anywhere in the world
through those mediums the law of Rhythm
is a law we have a biorism we go up and
down we live simultaneously on three
planes we're Triune beings we're
spiritual intellectual and physical well
all three is on a rhythm cycle and we
have critical highs and critical lows
that's when all three parts of us are on
a critical High
all three parts of us on a very low do
you know there's airlines that will not
let their pilots fly when they're on a
critical low they won't let them fly
they just ground them you can have this
charted I have people come up and ask me
questions sometimes I know what they
want to do they want to chart my rhythm
cycle and I give them the dates and the
things they want but when they bring it
to me I don't pay any attention to it I
don't want to know that I'm on a low
swing I want to know that I am in
control of me and I don't care whether
I'm on a low swing or a high swing I
don't even make it good because I'm
going to look for the good in it so we
understand that there's that time of the
month you know
that's not just for the girls that's for
the boys too because that is a rhythm
cycle in life and it affects all three
parts there's going to be Parts when
you're on a very high intellectually you
have a column of figurative room like
that you add them up another time you
add up that column you have to add it up
six times you get an after an answer
every time you're on a little swing and
flex like there's sometimes when you're
on a low swing emotionally you walk down
the street nothing's going right there's
other days you walk down there you're
skipping with the kids you're singing
with the birds you're on a high
it's a rhythm process of Life feeling is
a word we invented to describe our
conscious awareness of the vibration
we're in
when you are feeling bad you're in a
negative vibration
when you're feeling good you're in a
positive vibration that's just a basic
thing that we could go by
so how do you feel good well there's all
kinds of ways to feel good
think of something really Pleasant
you'll start feeling good do something
kind for somebody you'll start to feel
better
help somebody out somewhere you'll start
to feel good share a good idea you'll
start to feel good
when you're feeling good you're in a
Good Vibration you're going to attract
good stuff to you
most people don't understand that
feeling is conscious awareness of
vibration and the vibration you're in is
dictating what you're going to attract
oh
it's a basic thing it's so basic but
it's not understood focus is an act of
the Mind
you have a will
a will you have perception reason
imagination memory intuition and the
will
the will gives you the ability to focus
on one thing
how do you do that most people if they
focused on one thing for more than three
seconds they'd probably set a family
record most people turn Minds all over
the place
the most successful people are very
focused if you take and put a little dot
with a pen or a marker on the wall
opposite your favorite chair don't tell
anybody you're doing if they see it
they'll think it's a flyer so I won't
pay any attention but put a little black
dot or ink dot on the wall opposite your
favorite chair when you're sitting in
the chair practice totally relax and
stare at that black dot just stare at
that black dot now you're going to find
your mind will wander you only stare at
it for a millisecond and your mind will
be gone somewhere you'll hear something
a sound a siren and your mind's gone
don't feel bad about it bring it right
back to the dot bring back the dot bring
back and every time you sit in that
chair now if you'll turn turn that into
a habit I guarantee you you'll become
strong Focus I was working I was out on
the uh golf tournament one of the pros
and we were sitting around a room the
night between the two rounds and he
asked me about that and that's what I
taught him I said Sam relax and I went
to the opposite wall and I put a little
dot in the wall now I said focus on that
there's another way of doing it light a
candle in a candle holder and put the
candle somewhere near your favorite
chair and just stare at the flame
keep concentrating on the flame until
you become one with the flame
find your mind wander bring it back to
the flame now that's how you focus and
what you're doing is you're
strengthening your will when you do this
you're strengthening your will and and
once you get it strung you know you can
keep making it stronger it's like
anything it's like your body you
exercise it'll get strong and if you
don't it'll get very lethargic
develop your will that's how that's how
you develop the focus and can you
provide an affirmation well I anybody
can make an affirmation it's just a
positive statement from yourself to
yourself I always like I'm happy and
grateful I am so happy and grateful now
that
I have the ability to focus and I don't
take my mind off my focus so you see
when you see this and you know this and
you can focus that's when you're away to
the races logic is like an invisible
ceiling that most people never go
through they set goals some people say
well that's just not realistic
I wonder what the Wright brothers cause
their neighbors to think
you know it's just a little over 100
years ago 115 18 years ago that they got
us off the ground now think
do you think they let logic stop them no
one had ever flown
they were bicycle mechanics they weren't
Engineers they weren't flight Engineers
but they got us off the ground and look
at today I see that thing Boeing I think
it is have a great big Dreamliner I saw
a thing on television where taxes a
little bit and then turns this way
go straight up
hundreds of people on it
the Wright brothers would be turning
over their grave they saw that deal
happen
now think
logic
absolutely refused to let logic stop you
I had the Good Fortune of working with
fredman Hillary he was the first man to
stand on the top of Mount Everest I
worked on two or three occasions the
only thing different about him and
anybody else I know was his size very
big man she canceled concussion his hand
would wrap right around mine
he was a big man no one had ever been to
the top of the Mount Everest many people
died trying but he stood right on the
top and you know there's been over a
thousand people do it since then it
seems we're waiting for somebody else to
do things why don't you do it
why don't you do it although you cannot
change conditions or circumstance you
don't have to let them control you um
we can't control what's going on outside
but we can control what's going on
inside you know and unfortunately I
don't think many of us have been raised
to really understand that yeah and it's
a lack of understanding that's causing
all our problems
you know but how I mean how can you say
that to someone who's like well I don't
feel like I have control on the inside
when it seems like everything has power
over me what's something that could
still shift
you see the truth is for for that person
that would be true that they're being
controlled by outside
we look at it this way we are the only
creature on the planet
that's totally disoriented in our
environment
other little squirrels the birds the
every all the animals
are completely at home in their
environment they blend in you and I are
totally disoriented in our environment
we've been given the mental faculties to
create our own environment
however we go right through school and
we've never learned that
we have higher faculties and the average
person has no knowledge of how to
operate with them how to develop them we
have perception the will reason
imagination memory and intuition
now those mental faculties they're not
just words they're actually mental
faculties that we can use to take
control over our world and to create the
environment that we want
but unfortunately we grow up we don't
know that we've been raised to live
through by what we see hear smell taste
and touch
our physical senses and we're we've been
raised to be controlled by what's going
on outside
as little kids well you'll listen to
what I'm telling you well you'll look at
this you know and so it's all outside
um we get our report card and that tells
us what kind of student we are but it
really tells us where our mind was at
for a few minutes three weeks ago got
nothing to do with who we are so I think
we're
we're raised in ignorance actually
there's a very small percentage of the
population that
have a reasonably clear understanding of
who they are and what they're capable of
doing but the ones that do are in the
minority now
here you have your senses
see here smell taste touch you also have
an imagination your imagination is a
magnificent he'll said it's the most
marvelous miraculous inconceivably
powerful force the world's ever known
there's a power flowing into your
consciousness
it never stops it flows to and through
you you can actually photograph this
energy leaving your body
you can learn to read it too I could
read your energy like a book now as this
energy comes in your imagination gives
you the ability to build the picture and
you can build any picture you want and
what you want to do is with your
imagination build an image of something
absolutely incredible
and then you turn it over to your
subconscious mind this is the part the
early Greeks called the heart that's why
Solomon says as a person thinketh in
their heart so are they because whatever
is impressed has to be expressed
so it's the image that you impress that
controls the vibratory rate of the
physical body
I was working with Matt who's our in our
creative department and today and we've
been working on a special video that
we're going to be putting out you're
going to you'll hear about it and it's
on
attraction the law of attraction
do you see the law of attraction is
secondary law it's not a primary law if
you don't understand the law of
vibration you're never going to
understand the Law of Attraction and
everybody's impacted by that well the
visualizing is use the imagination
you've got to sit down and become the
actor and you start to see yourself with
the good that you desire and then as you
start to impress it this is your
emotional mind this is your intellectual
mind this is your emotional mind and as
you pass this over to them the emotional
mind it sets up a vibration in the body
and that's called feeling
so you're going to feel yourself already
with the good that you desire
now if you have to write a little note
to yourself and carry it around and hold
it in your hand and you just take a
little note hold it in your hand
every now and then stop for a few
minutes
go sit somewhere by yourself and totally
relax tell your body to relax it's your
body you're not a body you live in a
body so say just relax just relax in
fact try this right now
let all the muscles in your stomach
relax learn more relaxed Let It All Hang
Out come on just just let it hang out
now let your jaw relaxed
just let it relax you didn't even notice
your jaw wasn't relaxed just let it
relaxed now get yourself into a totally
relaxed State and then start holding the
picture and getting emotionally involved
with the good that you desire
I mentioned something yesterday I'm
going to mention it again because I
think it's very important get this book
this is Stella Adler's book
the art of acting it is an Incredible
Book
really good she was Marlon Brando's
teacher art of acting
you want to act like the person you want
to become way back 1900.
William James said that it's the actors
technique first of all the cause of fear
is ignorance
that is the cause of fear
and so if you follow the ignorance it
doesn't start out as fear
the ignorance starts out in a conscious
level as doubt and worry
that's on a conscious level where doting
or we're worrying then we take whatever
image comes into our consciousness of
the doubt and the worry and we turn it
over to our emotional mind that's what
causes the fear
well that fear then has to be expressed
through the body through the only
instrument it can be expressed through
our physical body it sets up a vibration
known as anxiety
anxiety is not expressed anxiety becomes
suppressed we suppress it
and the suppression then turns to
depression
which turns to disease which turns to
Decay you see you're talking about a
track a person gets on it's a very
negative track
it's ignorance
don't worry
fear anxiety suppression depression
disease disintegration
now the polar opposite of all that
the opposite of ignorance is knowledge
um
there's only one way to get to knowledge
and that is to study
um
now unfortunately
School
didn't do the job that it was designed
to do for most of us school should teach
us to love to study
not to dread studying and homework and
tests they should teach us to love it
because study leads to the opposite of
don't worry which is understanding
see a study that leads to understanding
we understand how to handle the fear
it's understanding that enables us to
cause us to understand where the fear
starts
the understanding then
we want to say what do we understand we
want to understand this whole universe
operates by law
one of the laws is the law of opposite
the opposite of don't worry is
understanding um
now if the don't worry leads to fear
what's understanding leads to
understanding leads to Faith
the faith leads to
expression
well-being
an expression
it's not depression it's not suppression
it's not anxiety the faith leads to
well-being
the well-being then is expression
acceleration because we're athies we're
not at there's not disease so you're
dealing with Polar Opposites there's two
different sides to things
and when we understand that
our world starts to change
it's by understanding that we learn how
to deal with these pandemics when they
hit and they will hit there will be
others there always has been all down
through history if you look back
there's been things like this happen in
the past
and unfortunately the masses are sort of
paralyzed by it the law of polarity
decrees everything is an opposite you
couldn't have been in without a note or
an up without a doubt without a cold
every positive has a negative so every
problem has an opportunity now the truth
is there's no such thing as problems or
opportunities everything just is it's
how we look at it it is what it is
that's it
now if we see something bad why don't we
say hold on a minute it's my perception
that's messed up here if I stare at this
long enough I'm going to see what's good
in it there has to be good in it you
couldn't have an insight to a room
without having an outside couldn't
possibly have up without Heaven down
that's just the law
a polarity it degrades everything as an
opposite I don't care what you look at
there's an option you see something
really good it's also real bad now think
of this if it's only a short way up onto
my desk it's only a short way down off
my desk if it's a Long Way to the Top
it's a long way instead of the bottom
you can't have a long way up in a short
way then it doesn't work that way
they're equal and opposite if it's very
good it's very bad if it's very bad it's
very good so you've got a big problem
get excited you got a big opportunity
how do we reshape our self-image to
serve us as opposed to bring us down
well
it's interesting molts
Maxwell malts actually discovered
self-image as we know it today
he was a cosmetic surgeon and he found
if he operated on a person maybe they
had a distasteful scar in their face and
he removed the scar
he said
sometimes there was a phenomenal change
in the person's personality
but he said other times they'd remove
the scar who was very successful no
change in their personality
that led him to postulate that we not
only have this physical image that
reflects back from the mirror we have an
inner image of ourself
it's how we see ourselves right now that
inner image is an idea
and that idea is generally
planted in our little life when we're
infants
and it's planted by virtue of the the
environment that we're surrounded by
how we're raised if a child's raised
with praise they're going to grow up
very confident individuals if a child is
raised with criticism they're going to
grow up very insecure
so you see this image that we have it's
a picture of how we see ourself
but most of us
that image was planted by people it
didn't know what the hell was going on
they didn't know the war was over and
they were planting they were developing
a little mind it was a mind they were
shaping it like fresh clay they didn't
understand that it was a kid they're
looking after him we feed him we keep
them warm up the hell you know that's
our responsibility no it was a mind and
they were developing that mind and if
they didn't understand what were they
going to put in well all they could give
it to the child is the insecurities that
they had themselves
so that was the picture that the kid
grows up of himself now I grew up very
insecure I was born during the
Depression when I first went to school
the second world war had just broken out
so everybody's rationed for everything
it was hard times all the men were away
fighting in Europe or South Pacific
there was no men doing nothing the women
that were there were driving the trucks
there were cops they did everything so
it wasn't a whole lot of time used for
developing a little mind
so I just grew up and picked up what I
could I got very insecure it wasn't
until I met a man that gave me this book
and gave me some damn good instruction
and I started to pay attention to who I
was
and I have never stopped being
fascinated with studying me yeah I I am
the most fascinating subject that I've
ever come across
and I have found out that you and I are
exactly the same we only appear to be
different
our physical body looks different we
choose different vocations some earns
more or less than the other
but our potentials exactly the same we
both live in a physical body
we both have these higher mental
faculties we're both Spiritual Beings we
both drawn an infinite source of supply
we're the same
so the trick I think for the person that
has insecurities that hasn't got the
strongest image they want they should
find a damn good Mentor
that's what changed my life
the energy in the room will be shifting
because it's the thinking of everyone
that creates the energy in the room
first of all you are an energy source
just your physical being in your mental
being it's an energy source and then as
you start thinking it's what you do with
this power as it flows in and to and
through you
[Music]
[Applause]
changes everything
now let's look at this
we want to be quiet
for five minutes and ask for direction
now
I'd venture to say there's a very very
few people that ever do that
I have turned into a habit when I get on
a plane
I'm a ritual when I get on a plane
when I go in the office first thing in
the morning it's a part of a ritual
I'm by myself it's very quiet music
playing it's very soft quiet music
I want the energy to be good
when I opened the studio
Sandy Gallagher sent me an enormous big
plant I mean it was big
and then at a birthday she sent me a
money tree
which is a nice plant it's a nice trade
those things flourish
I remember one time vanderwaal sang
very first million dollar Forum was in
Quebec
he had
a little
was it holds one rose
and in front of every person there was a
little of Oz it was one rose in it and
it was set up classroom style so you'd
look there'd be a just a line of them
and another line of them well there was
one woman
sat near the front her Rose died every
day no it's true and I remember Vander
while saying I wouldn't want to be
around a person where flowers don't
Prosper
now we say that a person that has plants
that work well in their home have a
green thumb no no
they got the right energy flowing
through them
plants impact your thinking
well the energy in that studio is
incredible it's so people come in there
if they're there for a little bit they
comment they say my it feels so good in
here and it does the plants are really
prospering
when I go in there in the morning I am
very quiet
and I ask for Direction
this is a great exercise I want you to
do that now
Pig a few minutes and be really quiet
you've got to get your whole being in a
very quiet vibration
realize your body's an instrument of
your mind and as you get these beautiful
quiet thoughts in your mind you'll put
your whole being in this great vibration
foreign
relax
totally relax it's not who you are that
holds you back it's who you think you're
not
[Music]
you know those quotes that you read from
time to time that tell you just how
phenomenal you are they're all true
do you know when you get talking about
the positive aspects of you and what
you're capable of you cannot exaggerate
you cannot
yep we just take a look at what's going
on around us in the world look at a
plane taking off go back and think of
what the Wright brothers did there that
flimsy little thing but they got it up
and they kept it up for about 14 seconds
they did it
everything's been improved from that
point because we keep expanding our
awareness
it's the same with the clothes we wear
the cars we drive the conveniences we
have in our home understand that
everything you see it was always here in
one state or in another somebody thought
it and because you can think it because
you got the idea you could do it
foreign
[Music]
it's not who you are that's holding you
back it's who you think you're not
self-confidence
is the first requisite
the Great undertakings
[Music]
I was saying last night before I did
that conference over in Orlando
I am
I can remember
first half decent sized audience I ever
spoke to
I was a basket case I was so nervous
somebody asked me yesterday just before
I remember you're nervous this is not
alone
very relaxed
[Music]
and I had to ask myself you know or I
thought I was
as relaxed because
of the awareness I've developed over the
years
and all the things I've studied that I
understand better
and it's this knowledge it gives you the
confidence confidence comes from
knowledge people say they don't have any
confidence it's not true they do have
confidence you're confident you can
drive your car
you're from you're confident you can get
dressed and put your makeup on or shave
you your company you can do all these
things see confidence comes with
knowledge and if you're looking at
something you don't have any confidence
understand you can develop confidence
all you have to do is gather some more
knowledge about it
it's the first record set of great
undertakings it's true one of the best
bits of advice that you were ever given
but to study
um
never stop studying
I am
I was in here in the studio a quarter to
five this morning
and
these are
things I was working on this morning
um
I have pieces of literature that I study
every morning
are you familiar with this book
power of awareness
and it has a red band across the bottom
make sure the maroon band
because there are different books this
is power of awareness by Neville but
make sure it's got this red band across
the bottom
done now he said determine imagination
thinking from the end is the beginning
of all miracles
that is so good so you imagine yourself
you've already done it you're already
there
and he said the future must become the
present in the imagination of the person
who would wisely and consciously create
circumstance
well
I've been studying this one page for
days
and I was on the phone with Sandy
Gallagher from about 8 30 till nine this
morning we were studying this one page
together and we were talking about where
we would apply it
um
the secret I think to Growing is study
and if you don't study you're going to
stay where you are
you have to keep studying I learned how
to study by when I worked with Earl
Nightingale
and I've got a book holder here on my
desk
it has a book open
now I've been reading those same two
pages for maybe three months
and it's the repetition of the
information
that alters the programming in our
subconscious mind Ralph Waldo Shrine
wrote a great book in tune with the
infinite
and then that he says nothing is good or
bad except your thinking makes it so
yeah
there's a law of Life Called Love
Clarity that law degree is everything as
an opposite
I'm inside the studio there'd be no
Insight if there wasn't an outside
you couldn't have enough without a doubt
you couldn't have a heart without a cold
well he says nothing's good or bad
except your thinking makes it so
the truth is everything just is
it just is
if you go and ask the Theologian Where's
God was God he says God is that's it
that's all they can tell you
the most astute Theologian in the world
that's all it is God is you're going to
ask the scientist
it's energy it's energy is that's that
they don't even know what energy is it
is that's it
well everything that happens in our life
it just is and then our perception of it
is going to dictate whether it's good or
bad
if we look for the good we're going to
find it
if we look for the bed we're going to
find that
when we have to train ourselves we have
to program ourselves to look for the
good
and you're going to find it why most
people
don't get what they want out of life
is it well they don't know what they
want
that's right you see
I got this
and then I got her all nightingale's
condensed narration of this on a long
playing record
and I'd listen that record over and over
and over again
one day
I was in the business in the cleaning
business I had sales people
and I had them Listen to This Record
every morning we listened to this record
and one day I said you know I'd love to
meet him
and I didn't know who Earl Nightingale
was he was a voice on a record that was
it I didn't even know where he lived
and a young guy that worked with me he
said no you wouldn't
is if you wanted to meet him you'd go
and meet him I thought damn he's right
so I phoned and I got an appointment
with him
now at the time he was the most listened
to man in the history of the
broadcasting industry he was a radio
broadcaster
and not an easy guy to get to but I got
to meet with him for an hour I flew to
Chicago
I spent an hour with them and when I was
leaving
I said Earl
what's the big deal you know
I mean what's it all about he says
there's no big deal he said it's
it's very simple he says simply decide
what you love to do and then dedicate
your life to it he's the problem with
most people they don't know what they
love to do they never take the time to
sit and ask themselves what they're
doing is trying to I think I can get
earn good money here I could do a good
you know it's great nearing some money
it's not what they love to do
well I was sitting there now I had
offices all over the place I had a lot
of people I was earning a lot of money
and I I got excited because I knew
exactly what I wanted to do I'm going to
do what he was doing
and I made up my mind sitting in his
office
that'd be
somewhere around 1965.
that I was going to go back and I was
going to work with him
and
in 1968
I moved to Chicago I left my own company
I moved to Chicago and I started to work
with them because you made it this far
no I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for some
incredible Bruce Lipton motivation check
the video right there next to me I think
you'll love it continue to believe and
I'll see you there the movie The Matrix
everyone thinks science fiction I go no
no that's a documentary everybody got
programmed that's a fact that's a
biological reality but what was
interesting they always said well
there's a red pill and you could take
the red pill you get out of the program
and I go